now I want to ask you Isaac something  you took a lot of anger a lot of people  on Twitter blamed you for ho doors death  and that's why I sat the two of you  together  I'd like I wanted a really awkward  conversation how did you feel about that  Twitter they got they got mad they were  sorry that's loco yeah I woke up to a  torn of few brands that way you're not  welcome here please all the why all the  f-bombs you want oh did you feel  Christian how did you okay how did you  interpret it did you interpret it that  it was his fault well any bitterness  towards bran at all if you're talking to  me or Hodor it's two different things  I'm apparently better towards them but  Hodor  I don't think who blames you  [Applause]